if you're a first person shooter player
at some point in your life you've
probably seen this
he just has a good gaming chair that's
right it's got the pewdiepie edition
that's
it right there today we're looking at
twitch streamers who got caught cheating
in game
they just can't help themselves as
annoying as this
is right being a streamer and cheating
that's just taking it to a whole new
level that i will never be able to
comprehend and
first up we have this guy called mr
golds
the best part about this is that people
in the chat are suspicious
they're calling him out you're way too
good at the game you must be using some
kind of cheat
we've all been there when we played
against someone like how do they do that
good recoil is it the first time you see
someone
good at the game i i just have a good
recoil
idiot ah you never seen anyone good edsd
fools
almost 2 000 people watching him that's
pretty damn good for twitch
i think so people are like whoa he's
insane with that sniper
and other guys are like yeah you can
hide it bro
now i'm talking with you guys because
you really it's right there
you idiot i i play and i look ahead
what does that mean huh what's going on
you know what i'm saying
what's going on guys have you ever seen
anyone playing no one's noticed it in
the chat
yeah what an arrogant piece of [ __ ]
someone came in we're like
hey oh god oh god
why has no one noticed that it's right
there yet
don't miss his chat aim at enemies on
oh that's that might help
oh he noticed it ah he just stopped
oh my god man i can't believe it i like
how he opened up his task manager
to just like prove that he wasn't using
a sheet
[ __ ] you his excuse later was that it
was an early april fool's joke
maybe he's trolling i don't know i can't
even tell people on twitch
are banned for like the smallest stuff
this should get you banned for life
right people largely look at streams
because they are good at the game
and they want to get become better so
they watch good players right
you should yeah they should be banned
for life in my opinion mr gold ended up
losing his twitch
channel after the incident no it was
still up i saw it
no he's done good good good on you
twitch
next up we have this little dweeb face
jarvis
he publicly cheated like how dumb can
you be
he thought it'd be funny for a video
no way
that's pretty fair i think that's kind
of fair what do you think that's kind of
fair that as well is kind of fair are
those all guys over there on the right
no no no i think i don't know what i
like these are the same people that are
involved in a crypto
uh pump and dump scheme right that was
supposed to be for charity
like holy [ __ ] stop make giving these
people an
audience god damn
what anybody sees someone jarvis is
about to eliminate before he gets them
i will give you a hundred dollars what
are you doing right now bro
i think this is aimbot
is that the requirement to be part of
phase
what am i doing what am i doing oh my
where are you
do they not understand that they're
they're ruining the game experience for
everyone
like cheating in games is such a problem
that it
it makes people want to stop playing
also i never understand
why why what's the phone i'm cheating
this is also doing multiple games right
it's not just one game to just test it
out see how it works
leave a like that's going to be a late
video but guys it's going to be a lit
video well it got him banned and he was
crying about it
i know now how big of a state this was
and like
there's nothing i can oh oh
oh oh oh whoa whoa whoa whoa so
hard
you know i'm still gonna love this game
no matter what oh
i just wish i could have known how badly
i was messing up i guess he's kind of
young though
i don't realize how young he was still
you should know better
this is probably one of the funniest
ones there will ever be
i've reacted to it before but i think
it's one of my favorite videos
you know because i'm female and
counter-strike people are like cheating
yeah that's that's really sad that's
really unfortunate
girl just because i'm a girl doesn't
mean i'm cheating just because i'm good
idiots shut the [ __ ] up yeah
stop shooting me oh what is that what is
that
okay cool because i'm female
all right what do we got here gotta load
uh gotta log my
load my settings there because i have
boobs
listen all right i can take my boobs and
smack you across the face
huh you want to talk to me now you want
to talk to me now yeah that's what i
thought
oh oh so we can see her cheat as well i
forgot about that
we get to see her point of view
that's normal she's so
terrible i just saw one construction
watch out purple
oh my god
why did i reload what the [ __ ] oh my god
i'm stupid
dude oh she's one of those that promote
their twitch in the
in their username nice trying to not be
a noob
what happened to the confidence huh
she just realizes
and he got that and now i have it i i
don't know what's why
it's weird i just love how they
where they try to talk out of it you
can't talk yourself
out of this you're caught what the [ __ ]
uh-huh changing tactic clyra hold on
claire give me one second maybe clara
let me just message this girl give me
one uh-huh why is this on my computer
right now
where is this how do i close this you'll
rock i need some help
because i don't you're a disgrace to all
female fps players
wondering if they ever caught clara i
need to text my friend
clara right now uh-huh she was at my
house earlier today
and she's the one that uh loaded up the
program and clicked load profile
as well right that yo
rock do you remember do you remember
when king clara
got the back man i hate her i hate that
[ __ ]
yeah she promised me she didn't use it
on my pc i'm [ __ ] done she was here
today and i was watching her why the
[ __ ]
why the [ __ ] [ __ ] this girl i just
realized that in my own [ __ ]
replay oh my god i'm gonna think i'm
gonna
just quit [ __ ] that girl oh you're gonna
quit
just not on your own volition trust me i
wish i could see chat
she cheats baits her teammate yeah right
and still can't get a kill
oh god it's painful isn't it all right a
small streamer
trying to make his way the screen has
the red squares around them
oh my god no way
you realize something i don't know
what's going on actually
oh my god
oh is there a wall hack on his squares
around him
he stopped he just hit the stream he
just ended the stream oh no
yeah he's using wall hacks
they came to make an excuse there was
wall hacks on my computer yesterday
okay i'm not denying that i just don't
know how they got there
oh clara it's [ __ ] clara
i knew it i knew that bay was observing
i just don't understand
i went to epic hacks.org
i bought the program i installed it and
loaded the conflict but i don't
understand
there was wall hacks on my computer
yesterday boom
he's done please tell me yep you're done
son
you're done i can't find the clips of
this but this guy wanted to be a pro
gamer right
and he was caught using uh wall hacks
you can see here
everything about him has just vanished
online he just deleted everything
i feel like this is more common than you
think where people cheat and probably
get away with it
even pro players do it right i heard
about
i don't know if it's true but i heard
about people using their mouse
anything you plug in as a usb to a
computer you know the program will load
so you can just bring your mouse and
keyboard to your tournament and stuff
like that
oh dream i forgot about dream uh i was
ready to wrap this up
it's like the biggest one ever oh god is
it even worth getting into
basically oh i still think it's
interesting because
dream made this uh speed run submitted
it
as a on i don't know if you did actually
i guess you need you need so much prior
knowledge about minecraft but basically
he cheated in his speedrun in minecraft
you have to be extremely lucky
to get a speed run in minecraft and it
became a whole deal of
well he's just too lucky there's no way
he he was able to get this
good drops and even mathematicians who
have nothing to do with minecraft made
videos on it stand up math did an
amazing video i recommend watching it
it's 40 minutes but it feels like two
four and it just explains how
you do the math there is a chance that
he could have done it
but you do the math and you realize no
there's actually no way he could have
done it
and it become became a whole spiel
between dream and the internet and his
fans and
defending him and people attacking him
and i don't want to
drag all that up again but i did find it
interesting
how after so long dream admitted to
cheating
and that the effect was that he had a
mod that
was giving him more favorable
drop rates in the game when
he could have just admitted that right
away and be like oh
i realized i had that my bad and this
whole thing could have been completely
avoided
it's not as bad as the other ones but it
definitely was the biggest cheating
thing probably
it's worth a mention i just find it
interesting it just takes out all the
fun in the game how badly do you want
people to think you're good i don't get
it
so yeah from now on anyone kills me
online i'm just gonna assume you're
cheating
or the real way to cheat is get the
pewdiepie keyboard
i mean unlock full gaming potential you
had this rig
no need to cheat baby that's it that's
that video thanks for watching if you
enjoyed subscribe for more see you
tomorrow
breakfast